this morning with a special honor for a
man who spent decades in prison for a
triple murder he did not commit kansas
city has declared june 7th kevin
strickland day strickland endured
missouri's longest known wrongful
conviction 43 years he was exonerated
and released from prison last year the
63 year old accepted the honor yesterday
but asked that it be renamed conscious
awareness day to remind us of all
wrongfully convicted people in missouri
give it to the people everybody that
rightly deserves it with the proper name
conscious awareness and let's do
something moving forward to
make the state pay
you know one of the things i struck by
he said i don't feel that i'm worthy of
that kind of attention i mean i did what
any person was determined to live to do
you just keep going 43 years wrongfully
convicted under missouri law he gets not
a penny nothing from the state for that
wrongful conviction but now he's got a
day named after yeah he does but it can
never take back the 43 years that he
lost but he said he's gonna move forward
yeah anywhere between three and 11 of
the people behind bars are wrongfully
convicted wow